Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Si conoces a una persona mayor zurda
probablemente tuvo que aprender
a escribir o comer con la mano derecha.
Y en muchas partes del mundo,
es todavía una práctica común forzar
a los niños a usar la mano "adecuada".
Incluso la palabra "derecha"
significa también 'correcto' o 'bueno',
y no sólo en inglés,
sino en muchos otros idiomas también.
Pero si está tan mal ser zurdo
entonces ¿por qué
sucede tanto?
Hoy en día, una décima parte
de la población mundial es zurda.
La evidencia arqueológica
muestra que se ha sido así
desde hace más de 500 mil años.
Un 10% de los restos humanos
presentan diferencias en la
longitud del brazo y la densidad ósea,
y con herramientas y artefactos antiguos
se pueden mostrar evidencias
del uso de la mano izquierda.
Y a pesar de que muchos pueden pensar
que no es una opción qué mano usar,
esto se puede predecir
incluso antes del nacimiento
basándonos en la posición
del feto en el útero.
Por lo tanto, si este aspecto es
innato, ¿significa que es genético?
Bueno, sí y no.
Los gemelos idénticos,
que tienen los mismos genes,
pueden tener diferentes manos dominantes.
De hecho, esto ocurre tan a menudo
como con cualquier otro par de hermanos.
Pero las posibilidades
de ser diestro o zurdo
están determinadas por la
mano dominante de sus padres
en proporciones
sorprendentemente altas.
Si tu padre es zurdo
pero tu madre es diestra,
tienes una posibilidad del
17% de haber nacido zurdo
mientras que dos diestros tendrán
un niño zurdo solo en 10% de los casos.
La mano dominante parece
ser una cuestión de suerte
pero las probabilidades
están en los genes.
Todo esto apunta que hay una razón
por la cual la evolución ha producido
esta pequeña proporción de zurdos,
y que ha perdurado
a lo largo del tiempo.
Y aunque ha habido varias teorías
que trataban de explicar
el por qué de la mano dominante
o por qué la mayoría
de las personas son diestras,
un modelo matemático reciente
sugiere que la proporción
actual refleja un equilibrio
entre las fuerzas competitivas y
cooperativas en la evolución humana.
Los beneficios de ser zurdo
son más claras en las actividades
que implican a un rival,
como un combate o
los deportes competitivos.
Por ejemplo, casi un 50% de los mejores
bateadores de béisbol eran zurdos.
¿Por qué?
Piensen en ello como
en una ventaja sorpresa.
Para empezar,
los zurdos son una minoría
tanto los contrincantes
diestros como los zurdos
pasarán la mayor parte de
su tiempo compitiendo
y practicando contra diestros.
Así que cuando los dos se enfrentan
el zurdo estará mejor preparado
contra este oponente diestro,
mientras el diestro no tanto.
Esta hipótesis del combate,
donde un desequilibrio en la población
se traduce en una ventaja para
los combatientes o atletas zurdos,
es un ejemplo de selección
pendiente de la frecuencia negativa.
Pero de acuerdo con los
principios de la evolución,
los grupos que tienen
una ventaja relativa
tienden a crecer hasta que
esa ventaja desaparece.
Si la gente solo luchara y
compitiera a largo de la evolución humana
la selección natural
generaría más zurdos
hasta que hubiera tantos
que ya no representaran
un activo preciado.
Así que en un mundo puramente competitivo,
el 50% de la población
sería zurda.
Pero la evolución del ser humano
se ha forjado a través de la cooperación,
así como el espíritu competitivo.
Y la presión cooperativa
empuja la distribución de la
mano dominante en la dirección opuesta.
En el golf, donde el rendimiento
no depende del oponente,
solo el 4% de los mejores
jugadores son zurdos,
un ejemplo del fenómeno más amplio
de compartir herramientas.
Así como los jóvenes golfistas
prometedores
puede encontrar más fácilmente
un juego de palos para diestros,
muchos de los instrumentos importantes
que han dado forma a la sociedad
fueron diseñados para
la mayoría diestra.
Porque los zurdos son peores
en el uso de estas herramientas,
y sufren de tasas de accidentes más altas,
ellos tendrían menos éxito en un
mundo puramente cooperativo,
y finalmente desaparecerían
de la población.
Así que al predecir
correctamente la distribución
de las personas zurdas
en la población general,
así como datos coincidentes
de varios deportes,
el modelo indica
que la persistencia de los zurdos
como una pequeña pero estable minoría
refleja un equilibrio
que origina de los efectos
competitivos y cooperantes
que actúan al mismo tiempo.
Y lo más fascinante
es lo que los números nos pueden
decir acerca de varias poblaciones.
De la distribución sesgada de la pata
dominante en los animales cooperantes
hasta el porcentaje
más grande de zurdos
en las sociedades de cazadores
recolectores competitivos.
Podemos incluso descubrir
que las respuestas
para algunos rompecabezas
de los albores de la evolución humana
ya están en nuestras manos.